femme des années 80 mais femme jusqu'au
bout des seins ayant réussi la marianne
de l'autorité et du charme des années 80
car ça s'en vient de s'ouvrir
vous êtes les marilyn comme monroe et
manson comme charles manson
ça vous est venu comment cette idée
d'accoupler le nom d'un tueur en série
satanistes avec le prénom d'une icône
glamour de l'amérique
b je voulais être la meilleure
représentation possible de l'ami
je veux le mans l'esprit en amour et le
pas
le seul avec maman dans un très vieil
appartement
bussard hasard
la garde républicaine accueil muamar
kadhafi au palais de l'elysée l'ancienne
bête noire des occidentaux
commanditaires d'acte terroriste a
désormais droit aux honneurs de la
république je ne joue pas alors j'ai pas
comme ça j'avais mal à rennes
la ola
[Musique]
j'aurais
à
nous avons
mieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le thème
quand
oui
l'ailé
je m'appelle emilie journée je m'appelle
et me
jali
je faisais partie
et vous tous deux vous tue sept tirs
[Musique]
voilà deux pleinement à la 2 dans ma
mère sortait le soir
eyquem laisser soeur la mère
bon ben on vient faire un petit tour au
bois de boulogne
et on connaît un endroit où on peut se
retrouver un peu dans une certaine
intimité pour faire cesser des imprévus
on revenait d'un long parcours
bon si vite et ils ont plus rayonnante
et d'habitude j'ai envie de jouer un
homard sauce tomate
il avait du poids de l'eau tact 10
aussi
une sorte de blague nous lieu vendredi
une andouille bercy
et memories
[Musique]
de respect
acculé tu fais la nuit c'est pourquoi
elles avaient péri
lalonde il est
non
les viols commis pendant la guerre
d'algérie ont toujours constitué un
tableau quasi impossible à lever 40 ans
plus tard la parole commence à se
libérer
henri pouillot appelé à alger en 1961
est l'un des rares militaires à avoir
témoigné sur le sujet
à
je ne sais plus comme
on finissait
un champ
j'ignore
c'est pas
un champ
on est arrivés dans l'est
genre
michel g
ce montant
puis là
[Musique]